hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think here and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of boardwalk
empire season four episode eight old
ship of zion so unlike the previous
episode where we covered a bunch of
different characters this one kind of
just focused on the chalky storyline and
the nookie storyline
so let's let's talk about the chalky
storyline just because it was the
craziest this episode you know we ended
with that that crazy fight yeah between
chalky and don parsons it was a bet it
was a great showdown i mean chalky
needed to snap out of it you need to get
woken up i mean nuffy calls him out goes
to the club calls him out and said look
man you gotta get your house in order
you need to wake up stuff's going down
he's just got his just just infatuate
with this girl yeah he's actually
obsessed like at the deacon's funeral
he's there his daughter called him out
he's like daddy you all right like
everybody's looking at he's all sweating
he's like what you know he's crazy at
the club like everywhere yeah so she
kind of you know because dr narcisse put
it put her there for that reason to
distract him right and with don purnsley
um the showdown with him we knew it was
coming eventually yeah he knew chalky
was going to find out right uh and and
you know that fight was pretty brutal i
mean that fight with that uh that broken
wood piece right through dom
yeah that was a great fight i mean it's
well choreographed raw just i mean we
kind of knew watching like we didn't
talk i was like
you know what's names he's gonna bust in
the door and help him out i thought he
was gonna shoot but i thought she was
gonna pick up the gun
she was making a plate in the kitchen so
she had a big knife and stabbed him with
i didn't see that coming but that was
great yeah and you know yeah chucky
almost choked to death yeah
he was struggling i mean even though
i think he knows that she did was
working back to narcissist the fact that
she did save him in the end i think you
know we'll buy him a little by her sorry
by her little grace hopefully i don't
know he may be mad he may hold a grudge
i don't know well he's he's definitely
not going to trust her anymore but this
will wake him up he will
be ready it's going to be war between
yeah
chalky yeah i'm looking forward to it i
mean with with i love that scene when
chalky comes to to dr nessie's play yeah
it was great the one that he wrote and
he got all like teary-eyed and emotional
over and everyone else was like whatever
right yeah uh it was cool to see chuck
come there interrupt it and just and
burn that heroin right in front of him
he's a i mean jeffrey writes first of
all is doing a great job with the acting
but it's just he's an interesting
character because
he does try to uplift his libyan
brothers you know the african-american
community but at the same time he's
throwing heroin in there yeah we know if
he's from harlem the downfall of harlem
and all that with the heroin it's like
he's just he's an interesting guy he's
bad but like he has this
warp sense of like like he's harder yeah
but he's putting people down there less
than him so we can control everything
but i'm like man you're no better than
chalky you know better than i'm actually
worse probably at least chalky's just
doing some alcohol and stuff he's a
lesser two evils and the club in general
is not i mean obviously alcohol is
illegal right but it's not that he's not
feeding heroin in the community yeah
it's not as bad and he's just i mean but
he thinks he's doing higher some higher
power some work i don't know he's crazy
and the question too is now with with
chalky knowing what's going on
can he get the community
behind him because
don purnsley is gonna he's dead let's
say they reveal the don purnsley you
know not they reveal but the community
finds out don personally is behind the
heroine and the death of the deacon
don personally is technically under
chalky's command it was a smart move it
was a good play dr narcissa and he knows
he used don the whole time again like he
didn't care about him being like
uplifted he was like uh here's a
here's a kind of a meathead type of guy
muscle guy that works for chalky that i
can use that i can use i mean the whole
time he was saying you use heroin to go
through people that are lesser than you
he was probably talking about dot i mean
not the dollars using heroin he's like
look i'm using you i mean he just don
just wasn't the brightest guy in the
world like i said i think chalky even
though he might not have the high
philosophical beliefs and all that but
he has a street smart so i think he
might be able to outsmart dr narcissus i
hope he does because you know you and i
both love michael kenneth williams
no i would not want him to die like him
in in half-face harrow right yeah my
favorite characters um so let's talk
about nucky
his whole storyline's kind of weaved in
with his nephew right uh will and his
brother eli
and now eli is kind of faced with this
similar situation of potentially
betraying nucky again again it's like
i hope he doesn't do it i hope the fact
that nothing spared his life the fact
that see i don't know what deal he made
we never saw if he actually gave the
knot no we still do the now we don't
know he's into the nod so
i hope that he sees it at his home his
his house is in order the kids playing
you know banging on like you know he's
playing a mean tune you know it's like i
hope that he sees that nookie even if he
went behind his back he did it for the
betterment of his family he wasn't
trying to hurt his body yeah i think eli
is just jealous of uh his son's
relationship with nothing because he
looks up to nike he sees him as the the
big man the guy to aspire to he doesn't
really you know pay attention to his dad
yeah he's a cool uncle i mean even he
seems like he even has a relationship
with sally fisher arquette's character
you know having breakfast with her it
seems like he's even kind of
into her in some way you know she
convinced him to like go back home and
make amends and all that stuff so
speaking of sally like
she's an interesting loving i like her
interest for uh for nookie she's like
she's feisty she's
you know she's also a bit manipulative
she she she plays mickey doyle
to get knucky jealous he's never had a
woman like i mean we don't know much
about his wife uh you know obviously she
died but you know i mean margaret
shorter was a little bit more timid a
little soft uh he had that singer
actress girl but she was just doing
whatever and then she of course from the
first season the i can't remember her
name the one was always drunk all the
time oh yeah it's kind of like
excellent because she had some off the
screen stuff with it whatever but uh uh
yeah she's smart uh picture arquette
sally she's smart uh she's feisty she's
strong she knows exactly what she wants
she knows how to manipulate men's you
know i mean she knows the game she's not
you know some small town country girl
she calls it she also got lucky to pay
her fifteen hundred dollars yes yes even
though it looked like he was painter he
looked guilty he was kind of looking
around like you know here you go like
get out of here yeah so she's good i
like i'm glad that she's around she's
good and then also we don't know if uh
taller seeing eli like is he just
bluffing about
getting his son in jail because
it
i don't know if he has that kind of pull
to be able to go in there because jay
edgar seems to be all manipulating him
all or you know using him in some ways
you know kind of he's not like the head
man at the fbi or anything yeah but i
mean can he actually go in there and get
the other guy
right
his old roommate released will's old
roommate released or testify against
will and get him in jail right like i
don't know if that's even possible
i kind of hope we get a little more
developed it's all over i mean
he's interesting but i want to see a
little more of him i think they kind of
show him as being this i want to know
more of his motivations like why he's
doing what he is doing i mean i like him
but i want to see a little more
character development with him why he's
so adamant about it yeah yeah
yeah i mean hoover i get because the
tuner is so famous i get hoover but i
want to see more about tolliver it's
episode eight yeah we're getting there
there's about 13 episodes a season about
so over there since we're over halfway
there i mean this is there's a lot of
stuff to wrap up what's lucky luciano
going to do in his his deal relationship
with meyer is he going to stick with him
is my going to go completely on his own
and then you have
capone and his
other brother that's left over and of
course uh um
yeah he could change his name yeah good
old agent van alden so i mean yeah
there's a lot of stuff to wrap up okay
you know we trust him yeah trust
boardwalk empire they always seem to be
able to bring everything together like
last i remember last season the last i
think
three episodes two or three episodes
were great they were just like yeah
they're just all like oh my god all this
stuff is happening so i'm kind of
expecting that to happen with this this
season because we haven't really seen
dr narcisse right in that completely you
know
antagonist role right he's got like men
fighting other you know gangs fighting
chalky yeah how does nucky get pulled
into that he's been so calm this is the
first episode we've kind of seen him
rattle a little bit he was a little on
edge so i'm going to be curious to see
now that chalky knows chalky's going to
be on the offensive now and the house
and rc narcissist going to react to that
seems like chalky now she has some men
working for him but chalky has like
manpower he's got like the gangsters guy
i mean it seems like he has more
manpower so let's see how he uses that
yeah all right guys so that's what we
thought of the episode you can post your
comments below on the website
thinkhero.com or on our youtube channel
uh think hero pro make sure to subscribe
to that or you can also come check us
out on twitter and talk to dennis and i
about anything tv shows what you're
watching borah empire uh come talk to us
at think hero i'm at griffinde and we
also have a facebook page that's a
facebook.comthinkherofans
and make sure you like that page and you
you share our videos on the workbook on
twitter or whatever all right guys
you